dans la calendrier quasiment déjà établi
côté russe côtière et vinsky bonjour et
à ces chiffres à la soviétique je le
disais jusqu'à plus de 99% il y a cette
prise de parole imminente de Vladimir
Poutine prestation devant la Douma il va
se passer quoi en Suisse
alors
je pense qu'il faut partir d'un
phénomène qui peut nous paraître étrange
pour répondre à votre question c'est
cette volonté
on ne sait pas d'où elle sort à vrai
dire de marquer une forme de légalisme
dans
l'organisation de ces référendums alors
c'est référendum oui on l'a dit pas de
campagne électorale pression sur les
électeurs
empêchement enfin tentative de
subordonner un certain nombre de témoins
qui pourraient être des électeurs
contraires etc etc donc ça ne tient
absolument pas debout et pourtant les
Russes tiennent à procéder à ça alors
vous allez voir qu'on va on va répondre
à votre question parce que il y a
probablement je Vladimir Poutine c'est
assez clair cette volonté jubilatoire de
poser de mettre l'Occident finalement
dans une situation ridicule je
m'explique ce référendum c'est
référendum au fond que fait Poutine il
dit vous voyez ce sont les procédures
auxquelles vous tenez ce sont vos totems
à vous occidentaux mais nous on s'en
fiche on les organise ils sont ridiculis
n'ont aucune raison d'être là mais on
fait on fait ça pour que vous vous soyez
amusé vous voyez c'est une façon de
dévoyer l'organisation évidemment
éminemment enfin d'un phénomène
démocratique une procédure démocratique
le référendum pour le tourner en
ridicule et dérision et donc j'en viens
à ce qui pourrait être la suite c'est
qu'à partir du moment où on Moscou
reconnaît ces régions comme partie
intégrante de la Fédération de Russie
cela signifie que toute
offensive militaire ou même escarmouche
qui aurait son aboutissement dans ses
territoires se réconcilier par Moscou
comme une agression d'un territoire de
la fédération de Russie et là évidemment
que peut-il se passer Poutine a évoqué
la menace nucléaire vraisemblablement
tactique en
Occident dit c'est la preuve qu'il est
aux abois moi je serai plus prudent que
cela mais en tout état de cause c'est
une manière de placer l'Occident en face
d'un d'un dilemme qui est celui qui
Vladimir Poutine affectionne ce dilemme
c'est quoi vous savez à propos de la
Crimée Poutine avait imaginé un dialogue
avec les les dirigeants
occidentaux en leur disant vous allez
vous battre pour la Crimée non vous
n'avez rien à faire de la crise nous on
sait pourquoi on se bat et là il est en
train de faire des choses pour le don de
base sauf que il y a beaucoup de soldats
russes qui ne savent pas pourquoi ils
combattent et c'est la raison pour
laquelle Vladimir Poutine a cherché
cette méthode de contournement des
défaites militaires par une action
politique qui aussi farfelue souhaitait
et bien lui permet de contourner
d'éviter le problème militaire dans un
premier temps juste une toute petite
remarque vous savez qu'il y a toujours
les idiots plutôt les imbéciles utiles
dans ce genre de cas de figure bien
avait encore n'avait encore c'était des
cinquième ou sixième couteau de tout de
beaucoup d'organisations d'extrême
droite européenne le Bloc Identitaire en
France et d'autres qui sont venus là
pour dire oui ce référendum est
parfaitement valide et tout se passe
très bien alors il y a évidemment
beaucoup de réactions après après ces
référendum les appels à durcir la
réponse face à Moscou multiplie on a
entendu l'Ukraine appelé ce matin encore
lieu l'OTAN le G7 a augmenté
immédiatement et significativement la
pression sur sur la Russie notamment en
imposant nouvelle sanctions en
augmentant aussi significativement
militaire à Kiev ça va être quoi la
réponse des Occidentaux et des Européens
parce que si on vous suit bien on est un
peu coincé aujourd'hui oui
d'ailleurs vous avez remarqué la
précipitation avec laquelle ces
référendum ont été organisés tenaient
précisément à l'avancée rapide des
troupes ukrainiennes est-ce que les
Russes ont craint c'est que avant même
que l'on puisse organiser ses référendum
les troupes ukrainiennes conquiert un
certain nombre de ces localités du don
de base notamment donc c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont allés très vite que peut-on
faire il est évident qu'avec cette
réserve énorme qui concerne
qui concerne des opérations militaires
éventuellement dans ces territoires
considérés comme la Fédération de Russie
par Moscou le risque est là en même
temps si des offensives ukrainiennes
peuvent permettre d'isoler complètement
ces régions dans un premier temps c'est
à dire de continuer sur la lancée qui
est celle actuelle oui pourquoi pas
c'est ça qui peut peut-être donner une
petite marge de manœuvre c'est une vraie
qu'elle est plus réduite depuis ces
merci beaucoup Gauthier pour le déc